hi I'm Anton Fuqua and today I'm going
to break down a scene for you from
equalizer 3.
you like being in other people's
business
I'm really beginning to like this place
and the people
I'm starting to believe from the bottom
of my heart
that this is where I'm supposed to be
so
whatever it is that you and your friends
do
please
do it somewhere else
well you know in the first one we talked
a lot about Robert finding a purpose in
equalizer one and Denzel created that
sort of wandering character who was sort
of trying to find his place there and
then two he was making peace of his past
he was trying to make peace of the past
his wife dying his friends betraying him
and the loss of Susan Melissa Leo's
character and in this one he's trying to
find a place for himself in the world to
just settle down and find peace so if
the characters on that Journey along the
way and of course in equalizer 3 it
starts off he's in a little darker place
and so that's when he starts to question
and contemplate the Revenge he takes on
these guys is it for himself or is it
still for the people he's helping he has
to pause to think about that for a
moment I think Robert McCall found
himself
a bit thrown back in time when you go to
those places like the in Italy
and people who've been there no it's all
old world you know the all the buildings
are built into the mountains it's very
classic and simple and I think that it
gave them a certain piece being there
you know right next to the Mediterranean
and
um
it makes you sort of slow down and take
a step back in time a simpler time in
life it's a fishing Village you live and
die on the sea very there's no cars I
mean a very few going up the narrow
roads kids play soccer right there in
the in the Piazza you know the priests
are still there with the church the
church is above everything so sort of
like always present it's very spiritual
place and Denzel used to get up early in
the morning like four in the morning
just to watch the sunrise over the Over
the Sea every day
you warning me I'm preparing you
[Laughter]
he's trying really really hard not to
get involved with the situation so
through that pain smile you know it's
like
I gave him a chance
you know he's like okay he's sort of
like the monster in him is coming out
you know that's what that's about he's
like if I gave him a chance
okay so he's gonna show him what it's
like to you know face a bully bigger
than you better than you you have to
think about it like sharks in the water
if you're on the beach with your family
and it's a beautiful day and the kids
are all in the water and then the shark
shows up you know the restaurant scene
you got family food music playing trying
to have a nice meal some Vino
and then the bad guys come in
right and all of a sudden the whole room
sort of changes the energy changes it's
not so safe in the water it's not safe
in the restaurant right that's the way I
sort of approach it there's sharks in
the water they smell blood
and they come
and but they what they don't know is
there's a bigger shark
you know sitting across from them which
they're about to meet
is that a Timex
boom well McCall asked Marco is that a
Timex I mean obviously needs to play on
time it's also you know he knows it's
not a Timex he just wants the guy to put
himself in the position that he puts
himself in and of course McCall takes
the uh the medium nerve which happened
to me before and it's very painful you
know and so that scene creates great
tension because it's a simple device
that causes great pain and it's like
tension it just holds the tension you
know so creating tension and up close
and personal like that you know instead
of a big event moment where the tables
are flipping and things like that it's a
simple thing that's very effective if
someone's in that position you know so
that to me is putting pressure on
someone the whole scene is about putting
pressure on Marco turning the tables on
Marco he comes into the scene to put
pressure on uh Geo the cop when he looks
over at Mccall the whole scene turns and
McCall decides to put the pressure on
Marco see how he how he likes how that
feels right of course it doesn't feel so
so good yeah so yeah but the medium
nerve gag actually a friend of mine did
that to me once very painful guys that
know how to do it know how to do it a
friend of mine who's a Navy SEAL I think
when I was doing Tears of the Sun he did
it to me to show me and oh my God man
you drop to your knees I mean you're
totally submissive right there right
there
that's the median nerve
that I'm impressing
on a scale from one to ten that's a two
that's a three you don't want me to go
to four I go to four you on
yourself I don't want that I don't want
that they don't want that
Denzel works with the stunt guys and
works with Andreas played Marco you know
we just kind of block it out and talk it
through and again when I do an action
scene to me it's like dialogue so
there's a a dialogue back and forth
between him and Marco it's just physical
right so we block it that way Denzel's
totally committed I mean completely
totally committed you know he's on the
set he's that character he's you know he
does his homework long before he gets on
the set maybe he's an actor first if you
told Denzel you're a movie star he
doesn't want to hear that he's an actor
that's why he does theater and things
like that it's like what makes Michael
Jordan Michael Jordan
you know what makes the greats great at
anything they're just totally committed
and then part of them they're just
special individuals some of them were
born to do just that not Denzel is one
of them he has that presence you have to
have that presence there are some actors
that just have that gravitar that
presence and that's what you get with
Denzel he's very intense even though on
the set when we're filming he's very
intense so you know if you're another
actor in front of Denzel
yeah you know you you better be ready
tell your Compadres
it's an actual restaurant in uh on the
Amalfi Coast uh in a all those
are real locations those are I think we
had maybe two sets maybe on the stage
but those are all locations that's in
Rome I'm officos in a which is a
town we use and Naples this one is more
of a I like to say a working man's hero
a common person's hero he's not fancy in
any way everything in it is doable if
you know how to do it you know if that's
what you do for a living there's very
little fanfare
in the action it's more up close and
personal and brutal in a very real way
and I think that's what separates the
equalizer that it's uh he's a common guy
and he doesn't do it for any Glory or
fame you you know he's the guy next door
I hope each film I get better you know
certainly each film I grow and learn
some things about myself as a filmmaker
as a person I know for sure I want to
make a film without violence next you
know I've learned I'm getting older now
I have children so you start to see the
world a little different it's fun to do
it's exciting for the audience but you
know I think I've um
I'm ready for another chapter